as new developments grow along main
street in the las vegas art district
near downtown some current business
owners are speaking out concerned
they'll have trouble keeping up with
rent as that area continues to grow and
as mary jane balleza reports not only
are costs of concern but so is the
authenticity of the neighborhood
the doors to fowler fine art on main
street and colorado avenue in the arts
district is now closed after the owner
priscilla fowler says she was forced to
move a couple blocks over to commerce
and utah due to high rent increases
she's not the only one moving to a new
spot jeff young owns modern antiques he
has a month to find a new location
that's that's really the trouble that i
see right now down here is just
affordability and keeping
the authenticity
of the area
intact which is seems to be going by the
wayside fowler's move is also temporary
she has four months to find a permanent
shop she can afford i wanted to know why
the city can't change the zoning or make
make it difficult for landlords to just
sit on on empty lots when this is
supposedly this is 18 blocks 18b
in the arts district destruction it was
set up by the city
for art related stuff and a bunch of
enterprising landlords came in and
bought it all up
and have been
releasing it a little bit at a time
while young is worried about the future
of the arts district he's hopeful he
won't have to move too far just seems
like the arts district is changing to
something completely different whereas
this is the local flavor
of the neighborhood this is what kind of
anchors the neighborhood down we would
like to stay down here you know that's
that's our goal i want to stay in the
arts district and grow with it and be a
part of it and i'm just hoping that we
can find something or work with some of
the landlords down here because there
are some really good landlords down here
you know unfortunately you know it's
property owning properties and business
just like anything else mary jane
villasa live local now